[Music]
good morning and welcome back to
our studio conf it's really really great
to see you
all here again whether it's in person or
on one of our live streams
but now it's my very great honor to
introduce
our next keynote speaker my colleague
and friend jenny bryan
jenny's work has almost certainly
touched you in some way whether it's one
of her books like happy get with r
or what they forgot to teach you or
perhaps it's because you're afraid that
you'll set your computer on fire because
you
said wd but
or maybe you maybe you're using one of
your packages like read excel or google
sheets to get data out of spreadsheets
whether it's excel
or google and into r but
of all the packages of all the work that
jenny has done i think
my favorite package is the replex
package
not only because it's such a great tool
to help you
get help from other people but i think
it's one of the rare packages
that has like no precedent in any other
package it's in any other programming
language it's something that's genuinely
new
so without further ado i'd like to
welcome ginny brian
so this i think is ours most
infamous error message object of type
closure is not subsettable it was my
title
as a joke for a while and then people
thought i should actually stick with it
so i have 20 years of experience
triggering this bug
which is why i can now do it in two
lines of code
and this is also i think commonly how it
actually happens although it's usually
never quite this clear
but you create your main data object you
call it dat
then you promptly lose all memory of
having done so
and you ask for the x column of df
which you haven't made but df exists
it's a function
that gives you the density of the f
distribution so what you've asked for
makes no
sense and art tells you this in this
very special way
and my my sort of
fantasy message down there is is maybe
maybe it would be able to somehow read
my mind which is
obviously not going to happen and so
this sets the mood for the next hour
where i want to talk about general
strategies
for coping with confusing and
frustrating situations
so you went into data science you were
probably told that it's going to be
glamour and fun
like 24 7 and you make
very creative concoctions that you
present
and people love to consume it but
there's all this
drudgery as there is in any job
where we actually spend a much greater
proportion of our time and our mental
energy
and so i've sort of made a a habit of
talking and teaching about those things
so that you feel really cool and have
fun
but you get your drudgery done as well
so we're not um
using slido for live questions although
you're welcome to ask them because i'm
going to blog
about this talk later but i am using
slido
live for some polls so if you're willing
to get your laptop or your computer out
your phone out i'm curious what your
current main debugging method is and if
you use multiple as you probably do you
will have to pick a favorite
and while i'm letting you take this poll
i'm going to say a few more words about
why i think this is so important the the
drudgery
part so if we don't give a name to these
things and give them dignity when you
lose half your day
to doing something like this it's
extremely demotivating
because you feel like you haven't
actually gotten any real work done
and the other risk especially with
debugging is if you're only reactive
and you're always dealing with today's
bug
it means that you are constantly putting
out fires and you don't probably have
the time
at that point to take to develop your
debugging skills
and be a little bit proactive about it
but you shouldn't be perpetually
surprised that there's a new bug like
really again
today this is going to happen every day
and it's actually worth
giving some thought to how you want to
do things so let's see
uh if anyone's responded
i think they have but it's difficult for
me to refresh
over here
it's a very complicated problem with how
i'm using this computer so
i am going to keep taking polls and i am
not
going to show you the results
and i will assume they are what i think
they should be which is that what's
probably all over the map there i will
reveal this in the promised blog post
as well so here's where we're gonna go
there's four sections of this talk and
i hope that there's something for
everyone here depending on
like your your our experience can be
quite little or quite a lot
and that there'll be something that you
find interesting useful or at least
makes you feel very validated in what
you do
and this is also basically approximately
the order in which i do these things
and they do all come up all the time on
most puzzling situations
so the first thing i want to talk about
is the beauty of resetting things
earlier this week we ran a ton of
workshops
i helped out in one i was not in charge
because i was doing this
and this reaffirmed my commitment to how
important the idea of resets is and why
it really should be your first strategy
so as soon as you get some sort of error
i don't know about you but
i immediately i just send that same
command again
because maybe it's gonna work this time
and it does not ever ever work
but there is a small variation on this
that is an extremely
productive implementation and it's the
world's most
famous troubleshooting advice for
anything
but especially tech because it's so hard
to get this right
that you should try turning it off and
turning it back on again
and why is that so this is a super corny
phrase
that we have all heard before that if
you love something you need to set it
free
and if it's really yours it will come
back and i think this applies
to unloved things as well so if you have
a strange
problem and it just actually doesn't
make much sense
consider setting it free restarting r
and see if it comes back okay so i want
you to restart our often
and especially when things get weird and
you might think i'm being glib
or i'm just trying to sweep some problem
under the rug but that is not actually
true it's like
one of the things that's pretty unusual
about r is we
we install and update packages from our
and this is a little bit like working on
your airplane engine while you're flying
and i think people updating and package
updating and installing packages while
they're doing work in r and especially
if they have multiple r sessions open
is a common reason why things get funky
in a way that's quite difficult
to debug and understand and the good
news is you don't have to
quit restart and you're guaranteed to
have
the package version that's loaded into
memory be the one that was installed on
disk
so that's an example of why this is a
legitimate way to reset things
so how do we actually do this in r so
this is the rstudio
version there is a menu
entry where you can restart r i have
this keyboard shortcut
emblazoned into my brain it's something
i do many times per day
and a second thing i recommend that you
consider this is kind of a big
lifestyle change so don't do it right
now
is to consider not
reloading your workspace at startup and
not
saving your workspace when you quit r
it's a pretty radical lifestyle change
yes
and i i get a lot of pushback on this so
i do appreciate the clapping i'm going
to remember that when i get
this week's pushback this is the the way
to do this if you were just starting r
in a terminal and i also just want to
use this as a proxy
for that figure i just showed you so you
can start r
with um command line flags including no
save
and no restored data and i want to argue
this is vastly superior to another thing
that a lot of us do and i have
lots of this on my computer from
previous years
where people use rm list equals ls
so that lists all the objects in the
global workspace
and it deletes them and so this is a
really common command to see
at the top of our scripts and believe me
this was my like 100
practice all the time but the problem is
it
it doesn't really go far enough so this
brings me to my next
poll and i'm going to continue to
believe that you're all filling out the
poll
and i want you to think about these
six r commands and they all have some
sort of effect
and then let's say you execute this
command rm list equals ls
which of these effects uh will persist
in the session after that and i will
give you a minute to do this because
this one requires a bit more thinking
you can select
you should be selecting multiple answers
and i didn't give you permission but you
are allowed to talk to your neighbor
which many of you clearly are
we encourage that it's not cheating
oh they're good okay
i hear there are responses so i'm going
to do the big reveal
so library d plier
leaves d plier attached so that persists
after rm list equals ls
redefining the summary function that's
been cleared
so you have reset summary to its normal
definition
if you've changed an option like strings
as factors from true to false
that persists in this session if you've
changed the language of the session that
it's going to affect what error messages
look like for example that persists
uh binding one two three four five to
the name
x that's gone x is gone but if you've
attached
an environment or a data frame to the
search path that's still there as well
and so all of those four
things that persist here aren't top of
mind
you're really thinking about those
objects but they all have
an effect on how your subsequent code
runs
and so this makes it very easy to
develop code
under a set of expectations that will
not hold
when someone else runs that code or when
you are running it in a fresh r session
so it's for that reason that i think
starting r in a way where you don't
reload the workspace and you don't save
it is vastly superior to this
practice because it's really like if you
care enough to
kill your workspace you care enough to
restart r
you should go that far so fresh starts
clean the workspace
reset options and environment variables
and clear the search path
and so i want us to think of this as
your r sessions are like
crops you grow them you harvest them
without any
fear not a house plant there's a there's
another
saying from the the cloud and vmworld
that's more morbid about livestock and
pets so this is our
slightly kinder gentler version of that
and this practice of um
kind of having no no memory in some
sense of of not loading your workspace
and not saving it
is pretty difficult to implement by
itself it really
works best in synergy with some other
habits in particular
saving your source is obviously very
important
so source is real and there's some other
habits that are quite important
so at the beginning i actually should
have mentioned this there's an rstood.io
debugging
short link and that will take you to a
readme on github
that has a lot of links related to the
talks that aren't in the slides
but if you want to follow up on some of
these ideas
so let's talk about reptrix i'm very
excited that hadley likes it
and i should really well we'll get to
this credit it's really a wrapper around
things other people have made but it's a
very handy wrapper i will have to say
and i'm kind of talking about the
package but i really want to talk about
the rep rex mindset more than anything
so you know that if i get a mistake the
first thing i do is i submit the same
command
again the next thing you might do is
sort of brood dither and fret about what
you've just
seen and a lot of people just
immediately go into
speculating usually about worst case
scenarios about what could possibly be
wrong
and this is this is just as effective as
submitting the same command again which
is to say that it is not effective
in the least and so one good way to
knock yourself
out of this paralysis is to work a small
example and you know for years i was a
statistics professor who cared about r
but i was by no means
a professional our programmer and then
over various years i started hanging out
more and more with the experts and
i think i've probably crossed the line
into being one of those experts now and
here's one of the things i learned i
used to think
that the experts just knew everything
all the
time and that's not true okay
they know some things for sure but a
bigger distinction is they have this
habit of working an example
so if there's a really weird situation
they test a theory
or they gather some data and
this is much more approachable as a
strategy
than trying to solve all your problems
all you have to do is work
one small example that sheds a new light
on the problem
confirms so-and-so's theory or rules
so-and-so's theory out
so the term minimum reproducible example
is pre-existing
it's important across all programming
languages and a minimal reproducible
example is much beloved in places like
stack overflow and github
and my colleague roman francois decided
to coin the term rep rex by mushing
those two words together
and at that same time i was creating
this package
mostly out of wild frustration with
code conversations with my students so i
use the name
and making a rep rex is both a science
and an art so the reproducible part
is the science part and that means
you've provided code that someone else
could actually run
and that's what the rep rex package can
help with it can only help
with sort of mechanical robotic things
but then there's this whole aspect about
the art of making a rep rex and that's
making it minimal and only humans really
can do that and so that comes with
having more and more experience
and if you can't instantly give yourself
more experience
you can hang out in places where you're
exposed to
good rep rexes all the time and you'll
start to absorb what the principles of
that are
so i'm about to show you a few tiny
snippets of code
that aren't quite complete and that
recapitulate
a lot of the struggles uh seen when
people
post examples and then we'll see a
nice beautiful rep rex so i want you to
sort of run this code
in your mind and identify
like what the mistake is like why is
there an error
and i'll give you a couple seconds to
look at this
so template is a string it's got
placeholders for an exclamation
and an adjective and then i call a
function praise
on it but this is not a function in base
r
so the error that we get is that it
can't find the function praise
so this is a problem that you see when
people post a lot of code but they don't
tell you which packages they're using
and you get to slowly sort of figure
that out through 20 questions
so here's another small variant of this
let's run that again in your head
imagine it in a fresh r
session not the one that we just used
so here we do remember to attach the
praise package
and then we call praise on template but
template
has not been divined here it might exist
on someone's computer
whoever ran that code but in terms of by
the time this code goes somewhere
again someone won't be able to run this
so
in this super tiny example this is what
a complete rev rex would look like
we we declare all of our dependencies we
are attaching the praise package
we create all of our inputs like this
template object
and then we do the thing we've come to
do which is to emit some praise
and so making this type of error and
correction
easier is one of the main reasons for
the rep rex package
is to sort of help people put their code
on a little spaceship
and send it somewhere to be executed in
isolation
and so the reproducible part is that
there's no reliance on hidden state or
secret things that i know that you don't
know
or that are true about my our session
that aren't true about yours
and another reason it's incredibly
important to provide
to express your problem in runnable code
is because of this
so i don't know if you've ever tried to
like help a relative
with a tech problem over the phone
but there's what someone thinks they're
doing i trust
like everyone has good intentions and
what they say they're doing
and then there's what they're actually
doing and
quite often this gap between these two
things like that's where the problem is
and so if all you're getting is what you
think and say you're doing
it's incredibly hard for someone else to
maybe help you troubleshoot things
so by providing your minimum
reproducible examples
as runnable code you get rid of all
sorts of opinions people have about
what's wrong
potential for vocabulary confusion where
you say potato i say potato and this
sort of stuff and it's much easier to
figure out what's actually
going on so to turn back to minimal
when you're trying to figure out what's
going on in a confusing situation you
can think of it as the classic
looking for a needle in a haystack
exercise
and so common sense would tell you that
if you can make that haystack smaller
it's going to be a lot easier to find
your needle and this is the basic
principle
behind why making a rep rex minimal is
so important
so your goal is to try to make the code
and the data
as small and simple as possible and if
you took anything else away
it wouldn't be making your point or it
wouldn't show the error
so i'm going to show a wild caught
problem
and this was kindly donated by brooke
matabonwu with her permission and so
this was a problem
she shared with me privately at first
and it's okay if you can't see all of
this code it's kind of the point the
meta point of this slide is
that wild caught puzzles
are complicated and so the main thing
you want to know here is that this is a
little data ingest
snippet it brings in a bunch of excel
worksheets that come from a bunch of
excel workbooks brings everything in as
a list of many many many data frames and
then
turns all the variables into character
and then out at the bottom
pops this completely mysterious message
error the
dot dot list does not contain three
elements so it's not at all clear
where in the pipeline that's coming from
or what she can actually do about it
and the thing i want to show here and
this was a legitimate problem that
needed to be solved
but this is like a wild caught example
by definition
probably uses private files that only
you have
in this case you know she needs 10 lines
of code to do what she's doing
that's just the complexity of what she's
doing
eight functions from five different
add-on packages
so we chat a little and brooke also goes
off and sort of ruthlessly minimizes
things and eventually this surfaces as
an issue
on deep lyer and by the time she was
done
this is what the rep rex looked like
that enabled
a coherent conversation to happen and it
was really more about
things were happening in various
packages and we gradually got a much
better error message here
but the key features are that we have
inlined data
she defines the data frame there and she
calls one function so
inline data not private data two lines
of code not
ten it involves one package not five one
function not eight
and this gets to the heart of matter
much quickly
so how how do you actually do this and i
would say one of the easiest places to
start
is simplifying the data so if the data
that
created your problem has 500 rows
why can't it have 499
why not 498 and like keep making it
smaller and you will
gradually reveal to yourself which
features
of that data frame are important for
showing the problem
so minimal repress has small simple
inputs it's awesome if you can inline
them
and no calls to packages or functions
that aren't actually needed
i watch a lot of the repositories for
our packages on github and there's a
certain type of
notification or actually it's usually
like 100 notifications i get at once
when hadley does issue triage
and so one of the things he will do is
he'll post
and he always says it this way slightly
more minimal rep rex
so i actually did a github search for
that phrase
and went and looked at these issue
threads and this is a sketchy diagram
because i like the way that looks but
this is actually based on data and a gg
flat 2 figure
and i counted the lines of code in
hadley's version
versus the original version and they are
consistently a lot
smaller and this is lines of code but
this would apply
to many measures of rep rex size
whatever that might mean
and you might say well jenny that's
great like hadley
hadley has special knowledge of these
packages and is maybe better at this
than i am
and that is possibly true but i think
there's something else going on
that makes me want to still
point out how important this is and
there are a lot of reasons to make a rep
rex
but somehow the
discipline of knowing that you're
preparing something to
show other people makes you like get
your ducks in a row
and it also consistently forces you to
minimize
things and a lot of people the the
numbers vary i obviously made these up
but a lot of people report that when
they finally decide that they're going
to post something on github or stack
overflow or
our studios community site 80 to 90
percent of the time
they solved their own problem because it
just got them working in a productive
way
and that won't happen every time and so
when it doesn't happen
it still means that you have this
beautiful version of your pain
that you can post somewhere in a way
that other people are more likely to
engage with it
okay we're going to move on in some
sense to the heart of the talk
maybe what you thought it would be which
is about proper debugging
but i do want to say i think the two
previous things are actually incredibly
important they don't feel like rocket
science
but they can prevent you from getting to
this point a lot
but so what if you haven't solved your
own problem and no one stepped forward
to solve it for you you have no choice
but to debug it yourself so i'm opening
another poll
that might be a little bit mysterious to
some of you
and we'll talk about this again at the
end so this will be open for a while but
so i want to know if you have ever
gotten
stuck in ours debugger
and answer this at will
so this mood i want to set here is this
is a pretty famous
far side cartoon about how we talk to
our dogs
where we express all these detailed
emotions or detailed instructions and
like we're pretty sure that all the dog
hears
is blah blah blah blah blah blah ginger
blah blah blah blah blah
and i think a lot of us
process error messages this way so
this is a real error message
it's it's going to strike fear in the
hearts of those of you who can actually
read it
it's the classic can't install our java
error message
and instead of reading all of this
detailed
information that might help you sort out
exactly what went wrong
i think a lot of us just see
error know failed
and go back into the speculate dither
and fret cycle
so these proper debugging tools are
nerdy
and they're technical and you're going
to have to push through
big ugly error messages or call stacks
but you can do it
so i'm going to show you a small example
in this section
of a function i've written called fruit
average
so the type of input that it takes is a
data frame where we have one column
for each piece of fruit and one row
for different fruit attributes so we
know that a blackberry
has four calories it weighs nine grams
and
my personal rating on yumminess is six
okay and so when you pass that object to
fruit average
and give it a pattern it'll find the
matching columns
and average their attributes okay
so that's what it looks like when we're
averaging two fruits
what if i asked for melon melon isn't in
this data set
so i get no fruits you could argue that
you know found zero fruits like
pluralization is really hard
i didn't get to spend a lot of time on
this but so that's fine it's not
beautiful
but it's fine for an early edge case
but here's a problem so if i asked for
the fruits whose name contained black
i thought maybe there'd be more than one
blackberry black currant
i get a weird message like found fruits
and then i get an error and the error is
about
row means being applied to minidat and
i'm being told that x
must be an array so i didn't call row
romaines
i didn't make minidat and i don't know
who x is
and so this is a common sort of
confusion situation
where you are going to have to slowly
figure out what all of those mean
you're going to fiddle around in the
bowels of fruit average to figure out
what's going on and is
does fruit average contain a bug or did
you somehow send
unexpected data so when i thought about
this part of the talk which is kind of
hard to deliver
in this setting because you can't all do
exercises and whatnot
i decided to take a tour through three
modes of true r debugging and i'm using
a death metaphor i think it's accurate
because we are talking about fatal
errors
so we're going to go through some things
from from the left side
to the right and they're basically in
order of probably what you should try
and also in order of how much control
you have so the least amount of control
is the death certificate
where you can just learn a few basic
facts
the next level up is you get to
participate in an autopsy
and you were actually allowed to examine
the subject
and then finally if you haven't watched
game of thrones
this creature is reanimating
a lot of dead people to create an army
but the idea is of reanimation or
resuscitation
so this is how i map these on to some
classic
r debugging strategies and we're going
to go through them in this order
so traceback is your first line of
defense i guess
where you can see what all was called
on the way to death so it is very much
like a death certificate where you get
some rather spare facts
if that doesn't allow you to solve your
problem you might go a little bit more
interventional
and you can change the error option in r
so that right before the function exits
like you're still on a one-way ticket
out
you can do an autopsy and inspect
the call stack but you can't really
change
the past at this point whereas if you
use browser and related techniques
you actually interrupt things before
death is inevitable
and get a much better opportunity to
maybe fix things so we're going to go
through these
so if i call fruit average on our
troublesome
example i get the error you immediately
would call trace back
here and where you do as you read this
from the bottom up and it shows you the
sequence of calls
that led to the error so you called
fruit average
apparently somewhere inside fruit
average on line five in fact
romaine's got called and somewhere
inside romaine's
there was a stop so this is called the
call stack
and that's a term that applies across
many many languages
in r we summon it with the function
traceback
so when i decided to do this topic i
thought i am finally going to get to the
bottom of what all those different
terms mean and it turns out that you can
take
any two of those words
and you can probably put them in any
order and
you will find some pocket of the r
community who uses that term
except call back which is real and is
totally different
but you hear people talk about the call
stack the trace back the stack trace and
the back trace
all the time and they all mean the same
thing
an alternative view that's coming
for back traces is from arlang
so arlang is accumulating more and more
functionality for
for developers really for throwing
classed errors
but one of the things it also offers is
some
new takes at how to present the call
stack
and that's the one part of that area of
arling that might be relevant to just
about anyone
mostly this is developer facing but this
is an alternative view of that same call
stack and it's
it's in a different order and there's
some nice nesting and so this is being
designed
uh with readability in mind so if you
like looking at
call stacks this way there's something
you can do in your startup file
and if you like using rstudio it also
has a really nice
default method for how to handle errors
and it will by default
show you the base are traced back and
then also
offer you an easy way to get to some of
the techniques that are coming next
so that's traceback so the last two
techniques i want to talk about are the
ones where you
get to intervene either intervene
post-death
in the autopsy or intervene even earlier
and um this is just a little video that
i think
totally evokes what's going on how it
feels that you get to open this
hidden door and go into this whole
world that has a microwave and a
refrigerator
and you can you can certainly look at
things and you might be able to do
things in there that's how it feels to
be in the debugger
it's less charming i have to say and
then you come back out
close the door and hopefully that hidden
world goes back to being hidden but
that's
kind of what's going on in these next
two techniques
so if you decide that you actually need
to see the state
of things uh at the time of an error you
can set your error option to the recover
function
so right as you're on your way out the
door
interrupt execution will pause and
you're allowed to look
at frames and those are the environments
corresponding to the different function
calls so i'm going to pick one here i
i want to see what minidat is okay
so we're in the usual interactive
r console but you know things are
special
because the prompt contains the word
browse and one which tells us which
frame we're in
and you can print objects here but a lot
of what people do here
is they use ls to see
which objects exist or in this case i'm
using
ls.stir to look at each
object in the environment and i am
particularly interested in
minidat because i know it's my nemesis
and i notice
that it's an integer vector and i know
from the error that it's being sent to
romaines which i'm pretty sure
needs a two-dimensional object so i
think many of you your spidey-sense is
already telling you
what the problem might be here if you do
this recover work
inside our studio it's great because
your usual
environment pain is brought to bear on
this problem and you can be looking
at the execution environments of those
functions
in the normal beautiful environment
viewer
but let's say so now i have a theory
about what's wrong
i think the fact that this somehow
became a vector is my problem
but now i want to sort of test that so
the final most interventional thing you
can possibly do
is we're going to use browser and so
this last debugging mode
is most powerful if you actually have
the source
of the function you're trying to work
with there are ways to get here without
that but it works best
when you do because you'll have
something called source references
so that was the first look you got at
the actual source of fruit average
and what i do is i insert a call to the
browser function
in the body of the function and
you want to insert it before the error
and if you knew where the error was we
wouldn't be having this conversation
so so you often want to stop start high
and then you can work it lower as you
learn more about the problem so i'm
putting it as the first line
and there are as i said other ways to
get into a similar
world that i simply don't have time to
cover
so in the istudio ide again if you've
got the source open
you can set what's called an ide
breakpoint
and that's what that red dot means and
then you're not editing your code
so a lot of people find that a nicer
workflow
and if you don't have the source to a
function
maybe it's in a package owned by someone
else and you haven't bothered to
download the source
or it's base r you can use debug to get
a fairly similar experience but it's a
little
more hampered by the fact that you don't
have the actual source
okay so this is a little video of me
live
browsering this problem
so first thing i do is i load i source
a version of fruit average that has that
browser call in it
then i'm going to immediately call it on
my usual troublesome
example and what you're going to see is
i
immediately get kicked into this
slightly different version
of the regular interactive our console
and the browse
thing will be in the prompt so i can use
n
now to go next line next line and i'm
walking through
that function it might be someone else's
function line by line
and finally we get to minidat so i'm
going to inspect
minidat very exhaustively and see what
it looks like
i'm going to see what its dimensions are
which are null because it's a vector
and how many columns this has which is
also null because it's a vector
and i'm pretty sure this is my problem
but here's the cool thing that you can't
do in any other
debugging mode is i can redefine
minidat and i'm going to do the same
subsetting
but i'm going to specify drop equals
false so that even if i get just one
column it's
still going to be a two-dimensional
object i check the dimensions again
and then i can resume at execution
and i'm going to get the error the
message i should see and i'm going to
get the result
i should see and so this is how you
sort of test a theory or pilot a
solution
to what you think might be going wrong
so that's what using browser and there's
different ways to get
into this world looks like
so to conclude this section uh every
time i've talked about this before
people come up to me afterwards to talk
about this they're like it must be in
the talk it has to be in the talk
so it's very easy and i certainly have
experienced this to myself to be in the
browser you think you're really clever
i'm going to upgrade my debugging skills
and you don't know how to get back out
of it
so you will never remember this but it's
capital q
okay if you're in our studio there is
also a helpful button a stop
button with a square that will get you
out of it
you'll eventually learn and then two
things that are more proactive to know
about
is if you've used debug on a function
it means every time you execute you're
going to get kicked
back into the browser undebug
on the same function is how you cancel
this behavior
and some people have been burned by this
so badly so many times that they have a
policy of only using debug once
and what it does is it will send you
into this environment browser
exactly once the first time you hit hit
that point and then never again
so it's sort of self-destructing so
those are all good to know about
our last section is more future facing
and it's how do you create your projects
in a way that they are less
hospitable to bugs and when things go
wrong because of course they're going to
you're giving yourself more information
to help you solve it
so if you've fixed something once or
you've seen some weird edge behavior
that causes all hell to break loose do
something to make sure that that stays
fixed and these
these tips are increasingly going to be
more package development focused
although some of it is relevant to
scripts but so based on the example we
just worked like a fruit average was in
a package i maintain
once i make that fix drop equals false
i also add this test to make sure
that the behavior is what it should be
when we have zero fruits
one fruit and two fruits matching
and so for people working with data
analysis and a data script
this is another hypothetical like let's
imagine you're importing fruit data on a
regular basis
and somewhere down in the pipeline
there's an implicit
assumption that everything's numeric and
maybe you've been burned
by having things unexpectedly import as
character
once you've spent a half day debugging
that uh you should add an
assertion in your pipeline so that the
next time that happens because you
probably can't prevent it
you at least know very early and you
have a really excellent error message
for yourself
so over time you're going to accumulate
lots of these sorts of checks
on whether you make a pipe data pipeline
or on a package
and so you want to be running them on
math
and really often so two great big
collections of checks that you could be
running and this is definitely about
packages now
is our command check itself will show
you
if your package is meeting all the
various criteria enforced by cram
and for the vast majority of those it's
it's a standard you want to meet
whether you're going to put your package
on crayon or not and something you'd
want to run really often
and then you're going to have custom
tests like the one i just showed you
that that uniquely tests the
functionality of your work
so our group uses a package called test
that
to express those and to sort of
choreograph the running
of them and when you set that up you can
run just them
and then it's also wired up that those
will run every time our command check
done
and this means you're much more likely
to run
all of your tests and the the sooner you
learn
that you broke something the easier it
is to fix it
because usually the delta is smaller and
you're looking in a smaller haystack
if you only run our command check every
10 months
you've made a very big haystack to look
through
and then the next level up is to run
those
checks not on your machine but on their
machine
and that pretty much means that you have
to be using
a whole another set of practices that
are beyond this talk
but that you are keeping your code under
version control
pushing it to a remote version control
host
like a github or a git lab or a bit
bucket
and you'll use something called
continuous integration and every time
you make a change
it will kick off running our command
check which includes your test
preferably over many different operating
systems
so you get extra credit here if you are
running it on different operating
systems
and again this just means that you find
errors sooner
when they're easier to fix this last
this particular point is extremely
personal
uh so i have found that there are
certain
patterns i will use inside a function
or certain data structures that later
prove to be very enriched for bugs
they're like bug magnets and
when i have to go back in and tinker
with that piece of code
i hate it so for me it's recursion and
high high dimensional data arrays like
big dimensional data cubes okay so if
you need that abstraction to solve your
problem
absolutely of course you should leave it
in
but if i'm honest with myself sometimes
i did this
because i could um
and both of these things i find make
perfect sense when you've been thinking
about
nothing but that problem for three days
and it just it's so elegant
and then you go away and six months
later this is where the bug will be
it is not so elegant anymore it takes a
long time to like upload
all of that back into your ram uh and so
i find
that uh if you have some pattern like
that where you kick yourself for using
it when you could have done something
simpler
stop doing that
here's a douglas adam quote that uh
i think has a lot of relevance to
building data packages
the major difference between a thing
that might go wrong and a thing that
cannot possibly go wrong is that when
the thing that cannot possibly goes
wrong
it's impossible to get out and repair
and so the idea i want to talk about
here is that as you're building things
you will be so happy later if you've
left yourself
some kind of an access panel and in this
case you know there's a valve here that
you can go in and turn off or up or down
and i'm not going to go through all of
the examples here but i'm going through
several packages near and dear to me and
i'm also showing
an example from base r where if you're
trying to debug
excel import or making http calls
or some sort of hairy non-standard
evaluation problem
you have a way to flip a switch and
suddenly be getting
a lot more information and this is great
for package
developers it's very useful during
development
and then also when you're trying to help
a user debug something
and you're having that sort of
vocabulary communication problem
you can ask them open the access panel
run your problem and send you a lot more
information that might help you get
unstuck
my last point is about writing error
messages
so we've come back to where we started
which is with the world or the r's most
famous error message
object of type closure is not
subsettable my theory is that the reason
this sends people for such a loop is the
word closure
and that a lot of people don't know what
that means so
we could also most cases use the word
function
there i'm not sure if that would
immediately make everyone love this
error message like i totally know what
to do now i can fix my problem
but i think it removes one communication
barrier in the tidy verse
we've been trying to create some sort of
standard for ourselves
for error messages where we
return as much information as we have
like where the error occurred
the name of the object involved if we're
pretty sure we have that right and maybe
even a hint
so this is a much more controversial
version of object of not of closure is
not subsettable
where we say i can't i can't subset a
function for you
have you forgotten to define a variable
named df so this is the type of
hint we give sometimes it's extremely
dangerous though
because people really trust you and
if you're wrong it gets really difficult
to predict
all the different ways people can get an
error message if you're wrong you're
going to send a lot of people on a wild
goose chase
so i'm not sure that this error is
really amenable to this
but a much cleaner example is from dplyr
so d plier has a function called filter
where you can ask for just certain rows
in a data set
and it's very easy to use the single
equal sign when you want the logical
double
equal sign and apparently enough people
have fallen down this
pothole that the deep flower retainers
have had mercy on all of us
and it's pretty clear what people mean
to suggest
maybe you need to be using the double
equals sign so i think of all the error
messages
that have hints this is my favorite and
it's the one that has helped me
the most so that brings us to the end
here i'm going to review
your troubleshooting blueprint okay so
something weird happens i think the very
first thing you should do
is turn it off and turn it on again
you'll be amazed how often your problem
is gone
if it's not gone try to make a rep rex
pretend like you're going to send it out
into the world
and you need to minimize it you need to
write a clean self-contained version
again you will be amazed how often that
process
gets you unstuck and leads to a
productive solution
if that doesn't work you will have to
dig into the error
and i really think using the proper
debugging tools
is very useful and i know that i put off
that day
way too long so if they look kind of
intimidating
i suggest that you time box it
so maybe say the next time i come up
with one of these
weird situations i'm gonna i'm gonna
fiddle around
with these trace back recover and
browser for 10 minutes
and if if i haven't really gotten
anywhere i have permission to quit
and go back to my old ways and i think
you'll find
that with just a little bit of usage you
get a lot better much more quickly
and then finally plan for the unexpected
so
you are clearly going to be debugging
everything you build
i'm sorry to tell you that and so you
might as well build it in such a way
that when it fails it fails
informatively
when you break things you learn quickly
and again just make it easier to recover
from the bugs that will inevitably come
up
so there's the short link again if you
want to see more links about the talk
get the slides they're kind of large so
i would recommend that you look at them
on speaker deck
but i really want to give big thanks to
two people
virtual people first the tidy verse team
has
listened to me practiced parts of this
talk for many many months
and i have to say that we actually
learned a lot about debugging from each
other
based on these every sort of two or
three week
conversations and part of why i want to
say that is um
a lot of this stuff maybe feels a bit
exotic especially the debugging section
and just let it be known that people on
the tidiers team
learned things by talking to each other
about this not not everything we talked
about
makes it into the talk it's more
technical but um
people don't talk about this enough i've
decided and ha people have cool tricks
to share with you and finally i want to
thank christine cooper who created
the beautiful visual dine for this talk
and
without further ado thank you very much
you